We have a voicemail number. That
number is two one nine two David P..
Here is one of our favorite callers from West
Texas. Take a listen to what he had to say.
This is a guy from West Texas. Again, I see
a president doing the same thing in Ukraine.
Do me a favor, though, tonight.
Tell the voters
I won't pass any stimulus bill unless you vote
for men and that you vote for when I get elected.
I'll give you some money
right as the same damn crap.
OK, yeah, that's that's exactly right. And
we talked about that last week, Trump saying,
if you elect me, I will do a middle class tax
cut. Well, hold on. I thought you already did
it. But if you didn't, why didn't you? And if you
did, why are you promising the same thing again?
Trump with the payroll tax cut. I will defer it
until my second term and then make it a permanent
deferral. If you reelect me, it's Trump saying,
I need you to do me a favor. You are absolutely
right. And there are more examples of it that
we've covered. And certainly, I'm sure more more
that will come up on the bonus show today. The
battle over that second corona virus stimulus bill
is getting completely outrageous with the
points of view from Democrats. Pelosi, Trump,
McConnell, the Republican Senate at large. We're
going to discuss it on today's bonus show. We
will also talk about the Supreme Court decision
allowing a three day extension for Pennsylvania
mail in ballots. That is a decision that could
determine the election. Most likely it won't. But
if we were to say which one state could swing the
election, Pennsylvania would be on the list. And
we're going to talk about it. And then lastly,
a majority now say the Senate should confirm
Amy CONI Barrett to the Supreme Court. What
happened? What changed? We will discuss all of
those stories and more on today's bonus show. How
do you get the bonus show? It's very easy. You go
to join Pacman dot com and you sign up. Coupon
code is available if you want a discount. Don't
feel obligated. It's available to anybody who
wants it. You can use the coupon code 20/20 now.
All one word, all lowercase, and that will save
you 66 percent off of the cost of a membership. I
will see you on the bonus show otherwise tomorrow.
And remember, tomorrow night, starting about a
half hour before the presidential debate.
About eight thirty p.m. Eastern Time,
we will be live on YouTube, Twitch and
Facebook. I hope you will join me then.